well danielle 10 years of applying to
big brother and you didn't make it to
the jury how does it feel to come so
close
uh you know what for the experience i
had i was ready to leave the house and
if i had to leave pre-jury i'm glad it
was fifth
uh so that i got as much as i could and
now i get to see family friends i get to
watch it back learn a lot and uh i look
forward to finale and speaking with
everyone specifically taylor but
hopefully uh we can all talk and uh
touch base again
so your final speech you call them bozos
you call them clowns do you regret
saying those things or no way they're
all clowns including myself so uh
i have no problem saying those things
because uh you know we all have a
different version of playing the game
and different strategies
and uh when they don't align you know it
doesn't help me out then you're a clown
do you really think the game's gonna be
boring without you in it
uh not necessarily me it's gonna be
boring with a mass alliance is my
opinion
but
now knowing how it formed and why it'll
be more interesting to see them turn on
each other now so that'll be the fun
part moving forward in the next
if they keep doing the pecking order
it'll be three weeks from now that they
actually have to turn on each other so
that'll be fun
you brought up another daniel a couple
times did you really study the way
daniel played the game
oh i'm a huge fan of dan giesling uh i
don't think i'm comparable i don't think
i'm him i didn't think i would have his
style of gameplay
um but i do honor him i do respect him i
look up to him but uh he's much more
likable and he has a much easier
approach with no emotion
do you think you were evicted because of
how things went down with taylor
uh mostly yes but also
because i'm outspoken it didn't even if
the taylor thing didn't happen i would
have said something somewhere that
someone would feel like he's probably
someone should get out because i'll call
people's game out in front of their face
i don't care and uh that would
definitely send me home on its own let
alone of course the taylor blow up
and there was accusations of bullying do
you regret kind of what went down with
her oh absolutely the more i learned i
haven't seen anything i don't have my
phone or anything like that um but the
more i'm learning throughout these
interviews definitely regret a lot of it
especially no now knowing
it were lies or
or my people that i trusted and what
laurel loyal to
maybe misheard and then there's a game
of telephone and then uh my emotions got
the best of me opposed to stepping back
and going how do we get to the bottom of
this is my biggest regret
and what did you think of your goodbye
messages specifically that of taylor's
and michael
uh they're a gold uh i'm a huge fan of
the show so i respect it and they're on
point michaels is more funny i love that
guy i think he's a great person and one
of the best players we've seen in a long
time
and taylor's was on point and i would
have said the same damn thing if i were
who do you think is going to go the
furthest
oh i think that yeah at this point top
three will be monty michael and taylor
um i think they'll cut taylor off on
uh the three so i think it'll be monty
and michael if the house doesn't open
their eyes and realize monty michael are
the best players in that house right now
but i am rooting for jasmine terrance
and joseph
and so what surprised you so much about
playing the game the game being a super
fan as you are
i think the biggest surprise was
feeling like i could remove emotion
or personal from game i thought dude go
in there and you have a task this is
your job you are you studied the show
you know who gets far so go do that
version uh we're all human it's a
pressure cooker emotions run high in
there everything's heightened in there
every day feels like a week and uh you
know every time you cry feels like it's
the worst day of your life and uh so i
was very surprised that i could not
remove the motion
uh which is dumb because we're human and
it's gonna happen
and you said earlier that you wanted to
make friends in the house do you think
that you did that
yeah i think i did that with the people
that i truly connected with i think
hopefully we'll all get along uh as you
know we assume that we could remove the
game from personal
but i found a best friend of nicole um
i found a sister in paloma and if it's
reciprocated it'll stay the same if not
i respect that um
found a best friend in terrence and i
love jasmine and hopefully that's the
same friendship outside
and how did you feel when you found out
about the leftovers
oh i respect it i look up to it i honor
it i think it's it's unfortunate that
was me but i as a fan i love that it
came together out of a negative
situation something positive happened
and how do you think the festy bestie
twist kind of changed the game
oh it ruined it
obviously like i'm ready to expect the
unexpected but uh
that definitely was out of left field i
was not prepared to play the game as
duos
um it was a thought going in but i
thought it'd be ex-girlfriends or
ex-boyfriends which would have been
crazier uh
but yeah i thought i threw that hoh the
get lit composition i really think i
would have beat turner that i still
stand by that but i threw it hoping to
get besties with kyle which now is the
why i'm reason why i'm out here so it's
it's crazy how it works but i'm a fan so
i also love it
so with this new twist how do you feel
about two separate games of big brother
going on simultaneously
what's
oh uh the bestie twist oh no oh i guess
yeah you don't know yet but i don't know
anything why are you what are you
dropping here the house is getting
splitted too
wait like half and half
i mean that kind of was already
happening
i would love to see how many of the
leftovers on the same team i hope
they're split up how did they even split
that up
can you tell us we're gonna i guess
we're gonna have to see i don't know
well
that's interesting uh two mass alliances
it could be really boring or it could be
really fun
amazing well it was so nice to speak
with you
everything pans out
oh my gosh i can't wait to watch back
everything and
realize what really went down you know
you